How do you keep a conversation going with
a stranger. In this video, I'm actually...
This is... Doesn't really count as a
stranger so we're going to set Mr. Buster
down and I'm actually going to... Stephen doesn't
know this yet. But Steven, my film master,
I'm going to ask him a question and we're going to
live demonstrate how to keep a conversation going
with a stranger. I'm Chad Littlefield, co-author
of Ask Powerful Questions Create Conversations
That Matter. And in this video, I hope to show
you how to do just that. Let's get into it.
So, for this video, I'm going to ask Steven
a question and we're going to have a little
mini conversation. And you're a part of this
conversation. So, you're kind of the observer
in this. And I'm going to show you one of the
techniques that we talk about. One of my actually
my favorite techniques that we talk about in the
book. So, let me pull up my We! Connect Cards
and ask Steven. Steven, what has been one of your
favorite moments in life. -Wow, one of my favorite
moments in life was I actually snuck into Disney
World because I was on a band trip and I forgot my
pass and I just snuck in behind somebody in
like one of those turnstiles. So.... -Whoa,
what's one of your favorite memories about
the person you were with when you did that?
-My favorite moment about the person I was
with there was that they they were kind of
in on it with me. And I was able to sort of
just you know, get really small and like go
right behind them and we kind of shared that
you know heist moment that makes sense. -Cool.
So, listen to what Steven just shared. From that
little response, what did we learn about steven?
Now, you couldn't see him. I was seeing his face
glowing as he's remembering sneaking behind the
lines in Disney. But we learned that Steven's been
to Disney. We learned that he was with somebody
when he went to Disney. Based on the face as he
was answering that, we learned that, I think,
he likes bending the rules a little bit perhaps,
right? And we can keep going. The further that
we go answering the question what did we learn
about Steven based on that response. Or for you,
what did you learn about whoever you're talking
to. That's probably the more relevant conversation
to be having here. If you're trying to unpack
how to keep a conversation going with a stranger
in your own context, one of the best ways is to
ask what did you learn about that person from what
they said? So, even if they spoke for 5 seconds or
5 minutes, what did you learn about that person?
Because every item that I learned about Steven,
I could turn into another question and it would
spin off into another tree of conversation.
So, I learned that he went to Disney. And so,
I could ask "Steven, when did you go to Disney
world?" -This was on a 11th grade band trip. So,
that would have been 2011. -So, now he's just
feeding me information, right? So, now, he's in
band. Right? So... And we didn't stage this. But
you can see how quickly that conversation actually
becomes exponential. And so, when you think about
how to keep a conversation going with a stranger,
when you ask how are you or where are you from or
what do you do, you get really stock responses.
Even with though those stock responses, you learn
things about who they are as a person. And when
you turn each of those items into a question, it
leaves you with genuinely unlimited possibilities
or directions on where you could potentially take
that conversation. Disclaimer: As I'm sitting here
recording a video about how to keep a conversation
going with a stranger, sometimes the best way to
keep a conversation going with a stranger is to
not. To just not keep the conversation going,
right? So, I don't know why you landed on this
video exactly. I don't know what it is that drew
you to want to unpack how to keep a conversation
with going with a stranger. I'm assuming
that it's because maybe you start a conversation
and it ends with like [Crickets] [Whistle]
"So...." Right? And that whatever that
awkward thing is you want to avoid that.
Now, sometimes you bump into a conversation, you
have a quick conversation like you don't need to
continue every conversation and turn it into this
big deep dive into the life of that person. And
it's just important to know that so that we don't
trap people in conversations that they don't want
to be in. Because conversations are not just
for you. You do learn lots of really cool stuff
through them but they're not just for
you. And if you treat them like that,
that's super selfish and it's treating the
other person as an object and I disapprove.
Cool. If you like that, I got a really
cool deck of cards. It'll keep you
uh talking with strangers for years and years and
years on end. Also wrote a book about how to make
conversations that matter. You can check out the
links in the description. Have an awesome day.